so for the rest but I ask you
to welcome or the cost which is going to talk to us
about machine learning and
show us some examples new skies
around these solutions
from where the blow exit no
so so
so photos
fn photo with a smile
peter velits ni all a united tweet from the
wedding cannes
[Music]
we suffered
jen clean and healthy computer by using
your browser options and baby in uk
online released his moves to get to get end
a vital match kamerhe did
ok ok
king the system avoids the start up on
david come and stay the night
it is moreover a cross passing
moussa sow but will not be enough for
me ksentini
[Music]
and nature it has
project series nhl street of rocks
our families it is  a species and
Japanese like women and here is
[Music]
a series of tests at china cargo and 10
8:16 p.m. instead olivia record five
games empty super tax so see pass
in French and I am pleased
to welcome  anthony passemar who is
our  pm klaba duty and who will explain to you
everything we do around
the lens or obviously extremely
important and critical for a lot
of companies
there are a few departures if you want to
get closer for those who are a
little further away  the back don't hesitate here it is
from a tony and I thank you in
advance thank you
indeed we are going to go back to French
it's done I think it's pleasant for
some of you I've been living in the city for ten
years  silicon valley so
i have a few anglicisms though
they come up from time to time so
i'm going to try to stay as close as possible
to good french
so yes my name is anthony passemar
i am i lead the haiti product teams
at google then also  another
product called pop saab I've been
with google for about eight
monks it's interesting I've been in
yaute and the cloud for about
four years I have different
cloud players and today at google  what
is very  exciting for me
google sorry
google is not new in the eye to
tiff obviously google has a lot
of experience in creating products
on the consumer side you have some
on the echez here we have the taste guilaume
android chrome castes  the
connected cars neste the google of the ass which is
back today in the company
this experience it was done on
quite enormous scales google home it is
still
something impressive the android phones I
remember many  games did not pass
100 million or more telephones that
are on the market
but it's true we are on a very very large
scale and this experience
has allowed us to explore a little
what is being done what can be done and at
what  scale we can do them in the
field of yaute so our
objective was to bring a platform
to our customers which allows objects
not only to become intelligent
but above all to have objects
which allow them to evolve in  ns time and who
learn so it's really our
objective at the aliotti level we
already have a lot of customers who do the
notice on google some have even
started on our new platform
which I will talk about a little later
in the  presentation others have been
there for a long time we are we
talked about it
the philips youla the connected numbers
of philips are also safe on google the
few that are interesting here
we at the company xix which is a
French company that makes boxes  who
puts himself in the cars and kirk who picks up
the milk charging the
car battery is more false also the detection
of slow punctures and therefore xix
picks up this data and uses an
algorithm a machine learning model
which was created by tell me  please what
is also another french company
which is based in montpellier and which does
the training of its algorithms on
google chad but then applies its
algorithms its  models on
two rails on connected objects or
not moreover
for a more direct exploitation
and closer to the problem so if they
use the algorithms of tellme
place and can prevent
car battery failures like that
it is  something that has
certainly happened to you me it has
happened to me several times you arrive in the
morning put the ignition on there is no
battery so often it is because
you left the lamp or the
children left it but sometimes  it's just
because the battery is too old and
it doesn't work anymore we would have liked
to know before going our
appointment was already late that's what
they do and work with midas in
particular who can raise  this
information provide them this service there
their customers so there we already see three
midas players and she googles me more it's
starting to look
quite nice but we work a lot
with partners we have smart parking
and energy works  they are two companies
that use our new platform
that we have just launched smart parking they
have boxes that are placed on
parking spaces in new zealand and
which detect the presence of cars or
not quite simply to say it is a
place is free it then allows
to have a mobile application for the
users to know where they
can park is what these intense
etc
they can also make the adaptation
of tariffs according to the flow
if a match if a  rugby match in
new zealand
perhaps they will increase the
rates to prevent people from taking
the car too much and taking public
transport instead it is true that parking rates can be
dynamically adapted
and they  have the same technology that
they have on their sponsors who go
to the car parks are starting to deploy
its to say smart city for two
space tubes so that's one of the customers
who has been using us since the
beginning of the baby  your private new products we are
very happy we work with them
the energy war who works with
electricity suppliers they are our moors and had
in fact he retrieves the
electricity data from the smarts from the smart meters
and then from the grid  and in fact corrects
all the errors the holes in the
data he often puts some
missing data it's not donations were
very very clean who arrive there are
missing data there are articles elsewhere
there are figures which are very strange
and  so they say all that a
bit with machine learning
they provide very,
very clean and complete information to
energy suppliers so that they can make
world predictions
load predictions on the network so it was very
interesting  not very very big yet
but which works which works great these
few examples of customers who
use the platform and through
this new one its customers to whom we discuss
we  always noticed three elements that
constantly recur
the first is security security this
is an extremely important point
in the yaute y since it is one of the
major obstacles to the adoption of the
llotja today there are three elements
in  security
there is how to prevent objects from
being done at the dock as there was with mira there
are surveillance cameras in asia
there is authentication of objects so that
we are sure that it is an object which
is ours or which  does well the one who
should connect that it is not a
copy and the third it is slow
data cription obviously which
by objects dances and especially in the
last two finally especially in
the inscription in fact there are always
constraints of  performance
of computing power of objects which title which works
on battery etc
so these are quite important subjects and
which adds beyond the friction in the
deployment of the tools so security
is a very important area  so much on
which we look a lot
the second c I did not know how to translate
what it I can not find the word
it is the scaling
it is how can you
make it so that that  you have
ten or a hundred objects where you
have 10 million objects or 30
million objects don't have to
take care of it so that's a big message if
you knew and a peeled who note
today  today the big message from google
is to say we take care of everything do
n't worry about that we know how to do that very
well
google has been doing that for a long time on a
lot of applications and so that's
something we're on  we're
strong enough
and the third point is that we do
n't do aio ti to plug in objects
it's not too interesting have made
loti because we want to derive value
from this  that seniors can recover
from what these objects do and above all be
able to change your
business improve it to be more competitive
be more  faster to be able to make
better decisions more
informed decisions so with its 3 these three
pillars we announced in May of this
year a new product which is the
first service of a suite to a
tool called clar d'haiti corps et
which is considered to be the gateway to
connected objects
halak the haiti platform until
claire d'haiti corps was announced it
was launched by the way at the end of September
until it was announced and launched
it  there were no managed services
to inject two
connected object objects into google you
were forced to use either
virtual machines or finally your
own your own machines your comments
deployment this is the first in a series
we did it in a way to connect to the
rest of the platform and that's
going to be a bit there our
payment platform will be called clanet gatti which
takes into account not only the
entrance doors the management of  objects but
also all the i  interaction of these flows
with other google services in
particular pop sums dataflow clac
worked then main paul the
databases and storage and then the
visualization and manipulation of
data
afterwards so we are going to delve a little
more into clara yeti body klaibi  body
is a as I said a 100%
manager service ouch really no
deployment to do no installation
there is no need to say that we hold
cluster size you have how many
devices you think you have
which  are going to be the charges etc it's
fully managed for you when
you log in to your platform
your google cloud console
it's something that happens which is
on the menu list at the bottom left
click on it and it's good you can
connect one object you can connect
10 million objects and absolutely nothing
has changed it's exactly the
same we will take care of the
up and down load depending on
what you ut  ilisez we
now support two protocols a small
island http same as titi it is I would say
from my experience about 70 80% of
industrial machine traffic
it is a protocol that is very well
done for machines since holy
for christmas  very light does not take
much battery does not take much
power and which is very well done to
have a permanent collection with the
cloud without using resources a little
better much better than the lhc tp in
fact but when we talk about a gateway
against  we're talking about a telephone or
slightly larger objects a TV an oven
often there are two http donations
support both and we'll eventually add
other protocols
we're talking about the pc we're talking about him
shovels  etc which will be added to the
platform over time, we have at the security level to
work on
the authentication of objects,
one important thing to remember for
the successful Corsican platform and that it
imposes a use  n of
digital certificates and public keys
private jets for the identification of objects
allows you to use your own
certificates and we validate them even if
you give us the certificate of your
certification authority we can put it in
your contract you put it  in your
counter antibody and any certificate
present or any key present must
have been validated by this
certification authority guarantees that this is your
new certificate valid your
certificate authority when I say certificate
people they always think of yahia
and alms objects  mass certificates
tact and she's it's gonna be too big it
doesn't hold my objections too constrained
I could never use this so
we did it in a way that
lets you do it even on
vice toddlers we have  in fact
our stack fits in ten kilos so
ten kilos that means that we
even see there no need to be in the
main processor of the obj  and to
be even in the
communication module and besides we have a
partner who does that there are
wifi communication modules with the
whole stac inside there is even no
need for a powerful processor anymore to
put a processor 8  bits it will work
anyway would have to
do registration and authentication
thanks to the method we use
to connect to tic gold without any
without lowering the
authentication security level bar that I
tell them  load distribution of skylink
all fairly supported two
important points of our platform like an
antibody is created on the
google network which is a planetary network
haiti body and planetary natively
c1 base you can connect objects
from all over the world
you  will always use
the closest google hotspot to the object
if you are in australia you will
reach the closest hotspot
called lighten up in a row google
fonta  ine closest to the object in
australia and then you are on the
fibers and the google backbone to go
to the datacenter where the data must be
because we have we know that you
want to have your data in europe in
belgium or in japan  in the united states but
you use the network the
google backbone to do it you don't use
the public internet network by getting
there first it's faster
it's more secure the google phones that's
what they  serve search youtube had
finally all the service google maps the
roofs that they don't fall that's a
trick alain tingaud device your objects
should be able to connect without too
many problems the second advantage of that
is that the object does not  doesn't need to
know where they are
just point to a small
island dot google.com and it will be on
point with its closest ones
so it makes
configuring objects a lot easier because when
you  can configure them then say j
I send it somewhere my son you do
n't know where it's going to be
it doesn't matter it will connect to
the closest point it will always be
super fast that's very interesting
and the consumption is also planetary
I went a little  fast on the
diagram before but all the data that
comes from cloud antibodies is put
no pope sow ben lobb sum which is
very much used by almost
all google services
today peoples and global it means that
if you have  an application in the
United States an application in France and
applications in Japan do not
necessarily need to know where
the device is located or on which people we are in
which region it has given will
subscribe a topic which will be linked to
rejections in the register of objects  who must
manage and will retrieve the give
regardless of where the give was posted
so it simplifies the
applications enormously and it gives above all
noted performances on a global scale which
are  which are native and which are part
of these products you absolutely don't
need to manage that it's important more
pop it gives you a temporary storage
of seven days if ever you
back and process are a little loaded
you always have subwoofer from  seven days
to recover your data
that's quite important to these natives
a second part in haiti body that
she of maize manager so there it is
really you are going to declare your objects
declared your registers declared all the
attributes of your objects you can
declare up to 500 attributes per object
and you can also communicate with the
freeze
the score is not only data management
it is also how we can
communicate with the objects of which we have
a notion of virtual representation
of  object in the cloud
you may have heard it under the
name 'digital twin', so in English
the idea of digital twins and that we have a repli
ation of the state of objects in th
cloud, that is to say  this U  x
brings me connected is open where it
is closed so it's a state so the
door will tell the cloud
I'm open that's fine I'm
open and I don't even have my block closed
so we'll see that in the cloud  and if
you want the door to close
don't go and connect directly to
the door because you connect
directly to the door that means the
door is an entry point and so
if you have millions of doors you
have millions of entry points on
your network and you completely open up
the attack surface of your network to
do that so what we do is the
door is connected to the cloud
the virtual representation of that
door you go  tell you I want
it to be closed and it is this
service that will communicate with the door via
an assignment that has been established in
advance first we go through the firewalls
and no worries and all the rights
of  access access security
monitoring everything  is log it is
done at the cloud level and no longer at
the object level so it is much
more much more secure and the
second interest of this interaction
by the cloud is that if I am
an application developer I  is developing
a mobile app to close or at my
door
I no longer need to manage in my
application is my door
accessible that it is plugged in that
it has not plugged in what state
it is in etc.
I will  just interfaced with the
virtual representation in the cloud
and it is this virtual representation
this service that will manage the interaction
with the device that the device funds lmcu
titillons http the app she doesn't care
she speaks http with the web or with  the
service
therefore greatly simplifies the
development of applications therefore it is
more secure it simplifies the
development of applications therefore
something very interesting at this
level when we have designed a small
body we have always ensured that  we
are a console you have to do everything in the
console with the mouse and keyboards
no worries you have all the
functionalities in the api and you
have all the functionalities in the
marine commandos if you need
so we really made sure that a
feature parity
if you're comfortable with api very
good if you're comfortable with the
console
very good that's no problem the
product was launched in public beta so
in september the aft very end of september  it's
been three weeks, we launched it at the same
time with a large network of partners,
we tried to ensure that, as
I explained earlier, and xittel ni
plos etc,
we tried to ensure that if a
customer needs to set up an
end-to-end solution his customers are
taxed a network of partners who have already
been connected and who have already done
the work before to work
with google and work with you so
we have two big  axes of partnership  iat and
the partnerships at the material level
we have milk rocci marvel intel does not expire
all-winners it was chinese it was jumping
created the tec the water no longer knows what
it is called very chinese action
so all of this is in fact  people
who have dev
boxes I have a few like
that they've been created that's had to code
that connects to ten bodies that have
documentation and that's been
validated that they can they can
work  whatever
partner you choose if you are in the
process of creating a new connected object
generally the relationship is not
completely exhaustive that is the team
that exists today but we
also work with others  like
attiyah and qualcomm for example they are
not on this list
so there we have a bit of everything we are not the ones
who sell these kits we work
with each of its partners so that
the team is validated at the level of the
presentations and that  was a code but it's
t not by google which in these kits
you can buy them on my other
adaf route
if several sites were needed like that
he is a member it is quite interesting
the other category of partners is
more in the analytics  haiti so we
have people like technip the osce I was
talking about this box that does machine
learning on new objects it's
a canadian box that
does analytics in particular for
all suppliers of wind turbine objects
so  it is for example people who have it
to customers who do big
industrial burns and its beautiful boys are
sold to customers but exploited by
the company which manufactures these terminals which
do the maintenance etc
so they need to have
give permanently so it is typically this
kind of client and who works
today
lawson that they have a role in jeans which this
plug on pop job which allows to do a
little bit what date does afloat but
with drag and  drop of two modules is
s  super well done that's a fashion that
I personally love so that
's really people already more
in the night x 90 x mango it's a bone
it's an art at ce1 which can turn
on  very small machines like the
expressiveness of the small breasts of the small
mcs had the same it was partners or san
hastily they have
ariotti body connectivity and nothing to manage you say
I am connected to gold ethics so it
generates certificates its general etc
the  sas upload sas created in the cloud
and connected that's pretty
fantastic there's one that I spend
a little more time with is
microchip macau cheap
they were the big leader in
teeth processor 8  bits
often the little things you find
in coffee machines under the
buttons stuck little 8 bit processor
and today they are very strong
in 32 bit and starting to go to 64
bit they have about I think 80
thousand  customers who use their
products they are real  ent everywhere
it's quite impressive and why
I love working with them is that hoisting
the only ones to offer a
cryptography chip which is 3 mm by three
millimeters which costs less than 50
cents and which
finally inside m  hook little preprogrammed
cc criquetot with your certificates and
your certificate authority and your
keys and then this ol crypt to all
the api to connect to an antibody
natively so we worked with them
for that which makes that in
any  object design today we
recommend putting a crypto
microchip because it fixes all that would
add little to the balms but it
greatly simplifies the putting online of
its drives because when the crypto is
sent
to manufacturers in China who will put
everything  that in the world of corn the
manufacturer in china does not have access to your
certificates that is rather a good
thing because it frequently happens that
they copy a little bit certificate
then be able to v  You only find
objects that are what we like about you
that are not yours you don't
know that they are not yours
so that's a bit of a problem so
there you are giving them a little little
vice and  they can only weld it on the
sweat on the final case so that's
pretty good protection and 2 against
the case will stand out for the
first time it will already have all the
authentication keys it will already have the
algorithms to do
the  authentication and crypto to
connect to the cloud in addition
the acceleration of cryptography by
this small chip greatly reduces
energy consumption so when I was
talking earlier about the terminal of
the wifi module which can have our stack
tls and our identification methodology
uses this crypto inside
so you have a a wi fi module a mc
eu so the 8 bit processor which
costs pennies and 1 sensor of the tip
sensor temperature sensor of fuzziness it
's kind of c  urthermore it doesn't come out of
what you want all that in
boxes that are going to cost maybe less
than 3 dollars in total
all inclusive with direct or
cloud crypto so that's really an added benefit
so we love working
with them because  that they really
they really understood the difficulty of
managing keys the difficulty of putting your
keys in both vice and the
difficulty of connecting beyond the
they completely removed all of its
difficulties with saying you put
this crypt up and  a son with the
processor is over you
wondered how much it costs
I haven't seen people talk about price before
it's still important especially when
there are a lot of a lot of boxes
so we tried to do that very  simple
the idea is that we don't want to
bill you for the number of number of boxes
or even 20 million miles declared in
the small body it costs you nothing we will
only bill you by use is therefore
basically the volume of data that is
transferred so that's really very
very simple it's the volume of data
so we have a free first plan the
first 250 megabytes per month are
free it allows us to start
quite easily with a few few
a few objects then to play a little
with behind there is little sobh top it's
10 gigabytes per month free so there you
are not this rather quiet
then we go the more you use the more
the prices go down
we go from 4.5 dollars per  giga in the
first slice at 45 cents per giga
when you go very very large volumes
very very large volumes of data
I was saying that it gives you
for authentication validation of
certificates creation of objects
creation of attributes and then also
all the  all the new
features that are going to be released by the
end of the year beginning of next year
on the item management of
the update two firms were etc
and so that's where it's  it's not really the beginning
but in terms of prices we tried
to be very competitive compared to
what is done on the market today I
think it's the most competitive
I'm not mistaken and since I come
from  some of our friends I know do
n't fall so here's to find out more
we've put almost everything online so
we can send you presentations
but it's not so much more more
complex creation on the site it's
club  for google.com slash haiti it's
quite simple there are saint paul codes
there's a bit of everything
it's quite easy we try to keep it
simple creating a lot of
content in terms of webinars and then
of course the kits  also so that
people can get used to that we
are new on the market so
obviously falcon we have to make ourselves
known
we are doing all this very
quickly but the platform is available
today it is yours  google account
so if you have to connect be  a
lot of objects and to recover this
data to be able to do all the
machine learning we have been hearing
about all day
we have to start by connecting the sheets
that's all thank you
[Applause]
I'm bastien works and she already has
this morning I'm going  talk to you today
about hybrid cloud
it was titled still on the screen
functionalities for the company
finally I decided to focus
on infrastructure and
hybrid infrastructure so hop
so as we said as I said  already
said this morning as I'll say it again main
as we'll say again in confusion
we talk a lot about big data a
machine learning but what we must not
forget is that we are also a
perfect cloud for the infrastructure for the
case  clamps for storage for
the ach pc we have everything we need for that
we are no longer behind our competitors
as we were maybe
two or three years ago and I will try to help
you  convince through this
pre  feeling
so here is a sample of our
products
you have here I think 80% of them and I have
circled what I call infrastructures
so the network the computer the
databases there is also security and
identities which in fact transverse I
think  on the three floors and so I won't talk
about big data from machine learning
we tale called google arabic the club
if it comes it's good I thought there weren't
too many batteries left so there are
plenty of good reasons to go on
the shine  I think that if you're here
it's because you're interested you
may have projects or questions
whether to optimize costs
make big data build
new applications make back
and mobile applications make them
monstrous micro-services at all
certain everything and certain reasons
to go to the public cloud and in fact
I don't know where you are either you
are still on a private cloud data
center so not even cloud so in vm or
in bear metal either and you want a
priori I hope so in any case go to
the right
the reality is that it will not be done
in six months
there may be startups the digital
natives who manage to go quickly  to
make revolutions it's
Germans decisions besides bottom up
but for you big account I think
you know very well that it will take
ten years maybe even more
you know very well that for a
long time there will still be plenty of
things in a premise don't corrupt the
same innovation cycles of what you
can do in the cloud and so you
're going to live between two tries between
two 10 years that's the focus of this
presentation
so just decoding rightscale analysis
says that  85% of companies will be multi-
cloud by multi-core they mean
there may be private there
may be public some public some
9% say all in the public 5% everything
in the private 1% no plan and in  the
four in the 85% you got  see there
58% hybrid that means private and
public and other hybrids in the
multi-class center so that public or
several private that's their vision of
things and gartner predicts 90% hybrid
so it's the bulk of the market and suddenly
it wants  say that
data center expenses will decrease from 55 to 45
billion between 2000 16 years started
last year until 2001 and that the
reverse the public cloud goes from a
market of 23 billion worldwide to 68 of
which understand why I want
talk about it
why we are there so that we do
events like that but I am
convinced that in the forty five
between the two there will not be more than 20
in the code in the infrastructure and
therefore there will also be a lot of  projects
coming from your companies the big
companies start ups are already
for the most part in the card so it is
you who are going in my opinion to dream of
all this business and it will be mainly through
infrastructure projects I also think
so why the  The hybrid cloud is
trying to have the best of both
worlds, i.e. innovating on the
public doing fps burst
disaster recovery was there are plenty
of other uses not all here do
london
but why still  private cloud
or hand prem it can be for
security reasons
compliance reasons cultural or
operational management reasons and therefore
not everything will work out public jobs we
are convinced of this and you surely have
an interest in  put some workloads
in the public cloud but others will
stay now if we dissect an
application package
we find these different floors so
any workload if they wanted what
constitutes a data application to
render middleware karim and it's in
the  As part of this presentation I am
focusing on four of its floors in
the same low order and I will
explain to you how we can hybridize and
that we are sure there is under going moreover
I was talking about d2 each  of these floors and
we are going to do it we have solutions
only google but in fact
most of the solutions will be with
partners such as quoting several of them
you will have a lot of logos and
architectures even if they are
detailed
what I know you remember  the
message that we are here we are in the ecosystem
but you are going to see a bit of everything that
exists on this subject so here are the four
that I have selected for this
presentation
let's go through the apps and the vm so
if we take  an application and that we
want free and service that we want to
put it partly on the public and
keep part of it on the man first you
can imagine a multi-
tier application I put its borders in the
public cloud where these global rubber bands
kept  database the bikes at home they
how to go about it the most
logical in fact there I think house will be
the easiest and the most obvious not the
easiest it's not the easiest
that's where it's at  'ideal sooner it is
to continue to target your apps very
clearly because by continue
risation we mean portability of a
doctor fall it runs on a phone
it runs on a laptop on an x
erver it's
bit like java that
m  90s the interest of containers not
only but it is a portability
so what we recommend is that
unfortunately we cannot
easily continue
there are constraints the sellers
the distances etc you cannot
modify them all your  legacy and suddenly we
have other solutions for that we have
partners
so I don't know if you know them
but that the lady has for example like
claude physical makes it possible to predict
migrations and therefore it is an
analytical platform which will allow  to optimize
to validate migrations upstream and to
stimulate therefore these migrations
I lost my notes happened thank you
claude physics allows us to simulate
cloud engine
I will talk about it in the next
in fact allows you to migrate machines
with agents who come to analyze
your machines and to migrate live without
losing without interruption in fact when
I of immigrants was migrated
part of it to stay in hybrid mode
ratha data he founded 5 straightens  and
hypervisors and schirrhein
he founds it's a mobility solution
for applications or
recovery and rollback
so we now have a
vm migration service which is used in fact
hard claden agents we wanted to
deploy in prem
quite simply they  will analyze your
existence without touching it without stopping it
they will then synchronize and
redeploy gcp environments so
the platform v th network and it is
necessary
all the bpc and start copying
the vm block by block to ensure
lossless migrations  of service and
you obviously have a multi
holding console in water which allows you to control it
very simply, it's a proven solution that
has been done for years now.
does it work which is widely used by
our customers who want
to make massive liechtenstein
now we're going to talk about runtimes get
you drunk cdu
essentially passes its
hybrid operating systems and in which
we will typically find this type of
configuration on  which we find
the containers the applications and
what you
may know that our orchestrator who will
manage these containers and below
which you are masters with us we have a
cloud platform is the manager version of the
vernet this public side and on the left  there
are plenty of solutions
I'm going to drink on a more
complicated scheme in
fact that way you can so we have plenty of
partners of the
tmx red hat pivotal with two versions
now of their
hybrid operating system and that hubert
netease allows with the federation  to
manage containers on soft loan in
the club so if we go by newton x
what you have here is their solution of
base who is in the center who is calm
her name they are also in
the conference is you have blue
print so applications
development of
application applications there are some on a store
you can create your own and it  will
therefore pilot via that hubert netease it is
still and always that fooled tease in
fact the aisne jean he will pilot the
deployment of these applications with
you on the left or with us on the right and
locally the system below them
that  they bernetti 10 that you register
directly on your bone it's acropolis
so it's the basic system that
manages adherence to machines and prism
allows monitoring the supervision of these
deployments
so here I want to have a drink pivotal
claude fonderie  that we announcing this
game partnership earlier this year
is actually what you see is that it
works on our case we love our
engineers have worked together
you can use pcf locally or
in our club and so that's  there even the
same architecture with us with them
I you with you and so they will manage
by and the deployment on both sides is
now more recently so that we
announced with pivotal again the
piloting service container whose Beijing s they are
called and  there in this case we
even created an open-source project havana
cuba which was born from the collaboration
between our agencies and the engineers google
recovers netease and the pivotal engineers
that we worked together for several
months which relate to who created
the  'perfect integration if you want
qpr netease in pivotal on google club
so we actually use bosch which their
castration system
which is therefore powered by qpr netease
so the version is always the latest they
are just two weeks behind the
open source version in  below which one
year 6 which is their solution resulting from
vmware which will allow the management
of infrastructures and they have a
strict regime and sports which register and
companies for  r store
container images so here's yet another
solution by piotta red hat openshift I
think you know who
also uses that fooled tease to motorize
deployments which works very well
on our map and which is that many
are already using at the beginning and therefore  all
these solutions allow you in fact
to ignore the datacenter whether it is
ours or yours and to deploy your
applications
from right to left and to break down
this famous barrier obviously if
you want it's more complicated but to
manage q26 directly  between m it is
possible and thanks to the federation
which was launched I believe a year ago
you can deploy on a cluster
that using press and on a coaster
that you manage laugh if you want it
on our vm or how many have  -tu for you
via contain and jean on our cloud and
human and they are also running
everywhere on the other classes and c2
is becoming the orchestrator
p  by default if you have followed news
a same heart to stop swarm they
considered that it is now that you
come netease the solution which is essential
as standard if you wish so
that's it it was for the runtime part
so  we have seen how we hybridize and
applications how we move the
vms how we can use operating
systems by our partners or
directly Cuban netease to
deploy on both sides now we are going to talk about the
network and so there I still have a few
diagrams am where l  had already seen it
's the google gcp network benefits from
the entire google prado network so
hundreds of points of presence where the
big cities the 17 dvd points but
said there are the machines all the edge
network and we have I  no longer know how much
300-400 no more than 800 global cash on
which there is our cd m on the docks
of youtube videos but grazer and
I try term
and suddenly to connect to it as
it is the network we can also be proud of  to
co  mpare with others but we are necessarily in the
most reachable in the world we have
several ways to connect there
direct peering peering via a career
which I showed you and vpn
which I recommend more for the text
is therefore the vpn precisely because  I
'm talking about it to quickly talk about it, we've
improved the offer
a lot, in fact, we've learned a lot with spotify,
for example, the two years about how to
ramp up,
so we support the latest cmp protocols,
have done bgp, etc., so
we have the gateway.  manager our
side we have on our site in terms of
documentation everything you need to
know how you connect your calls
what we give you good practices
etc
it's easy it's practical for the edf
test to start  with small
volumes even if we go up to 3 jtd
anyway but good for a hybrid cloud in
prod obviously don't know what I
recommend and it's more for the period phase
then in this offer that we have  renamed
anclades interconnects you have two
connection models the dedicated model
so you are the one who comes to connect
to our peering points in our
columns which is not
necessarily obvious it will depend on your
footprint if you have an asm if you
do you already have legs on the
interactions etc
if not the model via partner which will
be in 90% of the cases use which I will
speak about later and which brings
the same benefits
so the model
so we are still going to a few diagrams so
the dedicated model  direct it's you
arrive at a colo point on which
we are present so we have the whole list
I play in Algiers this after for a sound
for two in paris we will announce marseille
soon and we have plenty of water  in the
world
so you put yourself on it so we
connect the routers and we will be able to
connect your bonus with our club
on the same addressing plan so there
it is the same phase and a more
detailed view is always on the right
so we find the colo here the two
routers and we find the
addressing plans and so we will route is
automatically we will have a height frame
in each of the regions which will
allow route and packets and therefore your
applications will continue to see each other
as  on the same network and we are on
something ultra solid that can
go up on seals from 90
9 to 99.99 so things that are in
fact sized for the learner
we can do multi-region and
redon in  I will show later so
here are the access points our doors if
you want for the dedicated
interconnects on paris we have
interactions 7
the global switches and as I said we
in marseille soon we stayed on
paris already five points but for
the moment  two open and you have them
in all the big cities so
all these points serve as your
gateway to our network and you
join without problem behind a
Claude router to us and therefore you after
no it's connected from our back bone
different vo and pc if we are precisely
in multi region what will happen
is that as I said a
height frame so it can be
filled europe the us on each side our
back bone that connects everything and you
connect even on the only point
that we will be connected the two and
differentiate mine we see it here a sorry
it's the somewhat barbaric diagram 1 but
for those who are a little in  the middle
you will quickly understand
we have two two regions this time us
with a bpc we find the camp
areas and we connect to donkeys horses
different places we can get bored for
a critical network al business critical
where we actually have  of active active link and
two different regions
so that means that you have four
connection points so that we can
do ultra critical claude wood
on it without problem now the
solution maybe you will be able to
use these more easily if you don't  summer  s
not suddenly present on our
camp points it is via our partners so the
scheme is not much more complicated
basically the sincere partner between you and
us he is him on the camp with us and
we have a plethora and he will ensure it  is
he who will go to
you that is if you say you are I
don't know about one if you are not in
yourself an equinix not typically it is a
partner so for them it is  just a
local connection that make between their
different authors and then the
left part does not change so the
partners in
question here they are I think you know
they are the big ones to ride the hecto cros
career a connectivity worker
we even have some  smaller ones like
interclubs of French which will offer him
but also like the others of the
consulting of the sl and it is the interest of
these patassé who are agile is that they
can go to places where they
are not today  today something we
won't be able to make a water  who will be able to
come and connect you to us in this
in these areas
even if you have a less well
connected area they will actually make the effort to
do so it's part of their job
what here it's not going to be
left online at all it's  is a tree in fact of
decisions which allows you to know
according to your use case what to
use with us so you want to
stretch your network with us no well we
don't do anything it must not objects yes
is what you want  and tender on
just lass jesuit part where google api
if it's yes at that time is that
you can come directly live
last with us if yes direct peering
if not career peering the last
mail if you are looking for cloud
interconnect you find the  tree
for the photos if not if it is
for other projects so rather a brake
can you come to the
points of presence
yes
can you register yourself etc
yes so labels in  interconnect
if not ip sec and if it wasn't the
question before then it's going to
be super sexy you can't go well
with vpn at the initial solution ok
there's cc4 a way to connect to
nyon and last topic  who is therefore the
storage part explained to me how
hybrids and the apps how hybrids
and the run times how to
connect well since it is the ultra
critics the latency is also one
of the subjects for this type of workload which
cannot  be born if we are not
less than 10 milliseconds
some many will not even be able to
exist in yvelines on the other hand there is also
the storage aspect
so here again we have a series
of partners so send you this
here so big names in the  soca folks
you know real one stage
and it's also purer players and
i'm going to show 2.3 just so
a ship that we work with a
lot actually have even had to render been a
bit will provide both on  the  s
object aspects the block aspects
of hybridization solutions
that will make the burst at the object level
it's possible or says g20 of an app
years old it's the one that will manage above
hate terra we'll put it in the
cloud  it's very connected to cloud storage
it's also generally for
the initial integration of each of these
programs
if on the other hand you want an ace connected
full disk of vm between them to have
a buffet seemed to them something
that  are busy on the dirty side obviously of
prem and so that's a leading group
in cloud storage for once for
some it can even be seen for user uses
one of the good old
shared directories but it's very
used for butter great that
barely worth her terms and for the applications
obviously so that she no longer has to
know and there it's the same if it's angie
night if they will also manage the
synchronization between the prime and the
cloud
the use of the cp  like a file server
and don  it's a centralized solution
to manage your objects your files
and ignore once again it's the whole
principle of the hybrid of where
the object is in reality their solutions
know it he rattles looking for you one
last so  similar veritas their
360 console allows integration with cloud
storage
they do backup they do disaster
recovery background of archiving also a
real subject they are integrated and therefore
I did not put the diagrams for all saints
but you understand a little it is  same
mechanics
they plug in it integrates with our api
and suddenly you have the storage level classes extension those
were the four topics I
wanted to address in the case of the hybrid cloud
I'm a little bit ahead of it
so much the better we can move on to
questions and so what I'm trying to
tell you is what I hope you'll
remember is that you're still
completely prem or and that if you
think it's okay it's okay  do in more
than three months  employment as soon as
you are going to live for a certain
time on the hybrid
we have the solutions we have the ecosystem
we have the integration services to go
partners who can who
allow integration so we are there we have not
a lot of customers who get into this and
I think it will be the bulk of the market for
the next few years so don't hesitate,
we're here for that and that's it, so I'm going to
ask Grégoire
to go back up
so I just wanted to
thank you all  for your your
presence today it's been a long time in
this somewhat dark room so thank you
for your attention all your
questions
and then the big message we want to
pass on to you is really that we're here we
're here for a long time c  it is a
strategic investment for us
to be present in supporting
your companies to
transform you large companies are
on target
we are more and more numerous and we
can support you with a lot of
resources.  rces present locally but
also all our
engineering resources who as you can see on
stage at the moment are moving to
listen to your problems and be able
to support you so we are really trying
I think a key message is that we are
here we are here  for a long time and we are there
in an important way to
support you in this transformation
that these transformations count it
obviously consists in transforming your
business with data at the heart and
machine learning
but not only to transform all that and
to go in this direction there
well, we have to develop the
infrastructures with architectures
that will evolve that will go through
hybrid architecture sites, slap
as we told you
today so anyway a big
thank you for your presence your attentions
and then  just want to add that we are
there and we grasp what it is I
recognize until it vertical
and horizontal y do  nc we know how to do it
at the level of the sales forces, that is
to say if we have to climb the ladder
you know a strategy project and
wanted to discuss with our
vip engineering our vip star smoothing we
know how to do it there is no problem and we
we have to open we are in
auxerre which if you need a
dedicated google team for your projects since
you have a very big project you need
ten dedicated people we know how to do it
too we have already set up this  model
we already have customers on whom the
people on site send them people
for six months in twelve months
so we are a credit company also
is it beautiful in both directions
to accompany you
a big thank you and then so we will tell you
suggest we continue with a
drink at the same place we had
lunch thank you all and
[Music]
[Applause]